As another way of representing it,
the dragon of chaos stands for the
potential that surrounds us.
Inside of that,
there's the unknown,
the unknown that you actually come into
contact with,
right?
That's the unknown as it actually
manifests itself in your world as
something you don't understand,
instead of just the potential for that,
because we say,
look,
you know perfectly well that as you're
sitting here,
there's all sorts of things you don't
know everywhere,
but where are they?
Well,
they're not manifesting themselves at
the moment.
They're only in potential,
but you could.
We could have a discussion that that
became argumentative and then all of a
sudden it would be as if emissaries of
that unknown had entered the space and
that's the unknown that's defined in
relationship to what you know.
That's what you actually experienced.
Instead of it only being potential.
It's a tough thing to get because
they're both unknown,
right?
You think,
well,
how can there be two different
categories of unknown while latent and
manifest?
That's a good way of thinking about it.
You know,
you in a relationship,
it's going stable,
but you know that sooner or later
something will come up.
Okay,
op from where?
Why?
Up from beneath?
Well,
what do you mean beneath?
While it's from.
It's from your complex,
the person you're in,
a relationship with it in width is
complicated and complex that's implicit
in you.
It's,
it's inside your conceptual structure.
That's,
that's the way of looking at it now and
then when there's a disagreement,
it will manifest itself and you know
that you know that they're still trouble
brewing ahead,
interrelationship always,
and that's part of what keeps them
alive.
The interesting piece of empirical work
done on this awhile back,
so you might think,
well,
what is the optimal relationship look
like in terms of positive and negative
emotion?
You might say,
well,
Utopia,
nothing but positive interactions.
It's like no.
Now imagine you get people to code the
interactions they have with their
partner during the day.
You know,
you sample it,
you say,
was that interaction positive or
negative?
And then what you're trying to do is
predict the longevity of the
relationship.
Okay,
so here's the data.
If it falls under five positive
interactions to one negative
interaction,
the relationship doesn't continue.
Fair enough.
Too much negative.
That's easy to understand.
If it exceeds 11 positive to one
negative,
the relationship doesn't last.
Why?
No challenge,
right?
What do you want from your partner?
Bless.
No,
no,
no.
You don't.
You want periods of peace punctuated by
a good fight and that because that means
you respect them,
means you have something to offer each
other and it means that you're both
growing and so you don't want the fight
to be too dramatic because,
well then you retreat.
You can't settle it,
but the person that you can completely
map and who only does positive things
for you,
it's like a.
You don't know that person B,
they're not communicating with you nor
you with them.
Maybe they're just subordinating
themselves to you or you to them and
you're not growing.
You want someone who can.
It's a real relationship is a wrestling
match.
It's a grappling,
grappling phenomena that you both
emerged,
transformed from,
and that's what people want.
They don't want a pushover.
Not Not unless there's something wrong
with them,
and when narcissistic person who never
wants to be challenged will want a
partner who does nothing but deliver
exactly what they're told to deliver,
but they will mistreat the beyond belief
and perhaps deservedly so.